so as you know i publish an article
on the american conservative on the
symbolism of little nazex and one
division
and also just basically understanding
the satanic trope and the witchcraft
trope that we find in our culture
in the original video that i had
recorded that was deleted i had also
talked about the upside down pentagram
but in writing up the article
and hopefully it will actually be
recorded and put out as a video soon
it's being edited right now
in uh in doing the video form i just in
doing the article form i just couldn't
find room for the upside down
pentagram stuff and so i thought that
maybe i could use this as a patron on
the video a very strange thing i guess
to explain especially as lent
carries on but nonetheless i will just
give you a
slight uh
a basic idea of why the upside down
pentagram is used as a satanic symbol
and this might also be kind of a
counterbalance to the other video i did
where i tried to debunk the notion that
geometric shapes have
inherent meaning in the sense of
inherent moral meaning um and this may
be will be a way for people to
understand that yes i do believe that
certain images are used in terms of
satanic imagery or occult imagery and
that these
are done coherently that it's not
arbitrary why certain images are used so
get ready so we're going to talk about
the upside down pentagram
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so in order to understand the upside
down pentagram we must at first
understand the pentagram a pentagram is
we call it a star i mean the fact that
we think that this is a star
is uh let's say it's a very abstract
vision of what you actually see in the
heavens the fact that we have these
points instead of a pentagon for example
which then also has five points um has
to do with
the idea of a let's say
coming into to a very precise
manifestation so something that goes
into a point right it's like all this
potential kind of like a mountain you
could say so you can imagine kind of
like a mountain this point that goes
into a condensation or a concentration
of something that is what these
shapes that have points can help can
mean and so when you have many of them
they mean many points obviously that
sounds obvious but um and so in terms of
a uh
a pentagram the idea is because of the
way the pentagram appears when you see
it you know the right side up version it
it's a looks like a triangle a mountain
let's say and it then it has four points
on the side going sideways and then down
and so you can understand it as the idea
of a top point
which is
on top or let's say
above the four points
you can understand it as the top let's
say wielding authority over the bottom
so the origin of the upside upside-down
pentagram obviously comes from the from
magic it comes from uh let's say this
magical tradition that was installed in
the west um starting the late middle
ages and in the early renaissance and so
both the right side of pentagram and the
upside-down pentagram will be seen based
in kind of occult practices so you know
you have this image of course of the of
the the pentagram with the person
standing in the middle and doing some
kind of weird ritual
it doesn't mean that obviously both
sides can be used for strange purposes
but it the the ending across itself too
like you you know in magical theory
they'll also use crosses in different
images that are actually christian um
and so it doesn't mean that the
the geometric figure doesn't
have a certain amount of meaning in it
especially if you understand it in terms
of how it presents itself to you and so
you have to understand the pentagram as
this point this mountain with four
points on the side going sideways and
going down that's why it is often
represented as a man with the head above
and then the arms going out to the sides
and the legs coming down so you could
imagine it as the source of action and
then the embodiment of action you can
understand it as a building like a
pyramid itself that has four corners on
the
on the side and then moves up into a
point and you can understand it in many
ways in which the four which is really
an image of multiplicity itself is
united into the one so it could be the
four elements that are united into the
spiritual element in ether
uh or you know this this idea of spirit
that unites the four elements together
there are different there are different
ways in which th this very pattern which
is how four is united into one can
manifest itself and there is of course a
christian version of this which is
uh there are many because the the five
or the how four moves into one can be
represented as the pentagram but it can
also be represented in another way which
is the way that we often represent it in
on a die for example and so where you
have the four corners and you have a
point in the center which is uniting the
four corners together
so if you imagine the the four corners
and the one in the middle like this you
know you can think that you could flip
it this way and then you would have the
four corners with the the middle corner
above and then you have a pyramid um you
know whether you imagine in the middle
or above it has the kind of the same the
same meaning let's say
another example of this is in the notion
of the chariot and so the manner in
which four moves into one is represented
in scripture in the story of the divine
chariot in the story of the merkabah
where the prophet has a vision of these
four
beasts these four cherubs that are on
the corners and they are
they have their they're on wheels and
you have this sense that they're they
are moving and then the rider descends
upon the chariot the son of man descends
and this becomes the vehicle
for the glory of god to manifest itself
and so i mean it's not think about the
ark of the covenant for example which
has the same pattern you have the four
corners of the ark you have a box and
then on top of the box then you have the
glory of god which descends and is the
manner in which the box or the stability
of manifestation unites itself into a
head okay
so that's basically the notion of the
pentagram or the four that moves into
one like i said it's not just limited to
a pentagram
and you have christian virgins of that
the the two christian virgins that you
can see of that are related to each
other
one is the
the image of christ in glory with the
four glories on the side and so you have
christ and his head and you have the
halo in the middle of christ which is
the head the way in which the four unite
and then you have the four beasts on the
corners and those four beasts are also
the four evangelists
so you can imagine a structure where you
have the four gospels the four
evangelists the four beasts and then
christ which unites this multiplicity
together into one
and it really is an image about how
reality works and how
multiplicity creates multiplicity
for creates a stab a stability because
you have two sets of opposites you have
this
this vehicle that is actually stable
whereas duality doesn't have that
capacity and neither does uh does three
because three is dynamic it has a
dynamic quality which is that the three
are always related to each other in a
more dynamic quality which is why the
trinity is a is three but four
has this kind of stable incarnate manner
and so obviously like i said imagine
your arms and your legs uh this these
two feet below and then these two arms
acting in the world um or you can
imagine an animal with four legs and
then above a house all of this four and
one
another version of how the
pentagram or the four moving into one
appears is in the very
structure of an orthodox church which
has a dome
in the center and you have christ up in
the dome at the top of the pattern and
then you have on the side you have
what's called pentatives these pendants
are four corners
that move into columns that hold up the
dome
and the four corners are like are really
like four points there these are four
points in the corners and in the the top
so you can imagine it of course
straight like in a die where you see the
four dots and the one in the middle but
but because it's a dome it's obviously
flipped like i told you like this before
the four corners and then the rider at
the top or the summit of the pyramid or
the summit of the of this four at the
top okay um and so that is really let's
say this understanding of the pentagram
but it can also have dark implications
just like any type of symbolism it can
also represent the idea of will as
supreme over the world let's say and so
the idea of man who rules over the four
elements
there are different ways of
understanding it and that's why in
magical rituals a pentagram might be
used in order to
subject reality to your will in order to
create a space in which you are capable
of influencing the the way the world
lays itself out through ritual and
through magical pronunciations okay um
so that's the basic idea of a pentagram
now
the reason why the pentagram upside down
pentagram ended up being used in
satanism has to do with the idea of
black magic right so you can imagine you
have white magic with the the pentagram
going up and the four moving into one
above and then you have black magic
which was the opposite which is upside
down that's why we say an upside down
pentagram or
which i mean it's kind of funny because
obviously the idea that this geometric
shape has a right side up and uh and uh
you know upside down is obviously might
seem arbitrary at first but it's not
arbitrary once you can see that we
intuitively find meaning in this type of
symbolism um so you can imagine that the
upside-down pentagram is the opposite
it's something like
the source of unity comes from
multiplicity it's something like uh
giving in to multiplicity in order to
find some kind of power that'll
concentrate in you and so you can
imagine that's why it's something like
invoking demons it's uh you know
giving up your soul to receive some kind
of particular power that is going to
land down down there um
so you can understand why that would be
satanic in the sense that that's what
satanism is right satanism is an upside
down reality it's a giving in to your
ends up being a giving in to your
different passions giving in to the and
it is in a certain way it's kind of
atheistic and it believes that
multiplicity can give unity and so
that's why it appears upside down and
that's also why it's the image of the
goat
the goat that you see in um
kind of black magic symbolism
has to do with the goat in scripture the
goat that is cast out the goat that is
given to azazel and so there is a sense
in kind of upside down uh black magic
that this residue like the stuff that
you that you
throw away
has a kind of power if you're able to
tap into it if you tap into the into the
residue then there's something hidden in
that power that you can use to give
yourself uh authority and so if i had
said that to you 100 years ago or 200
years ago you might have thought that
i'm just making it up or that it's
arbitrary but you just have to look
around you and notice that
all of the social narrative right now
all of the power is going to those who
are able to tap in to the power of the
residue tap into the power of that which
doesn't fit in tap into the power of the
exception of the leftover of all this
idea of the margin this is how the
current social narrative is being run is
in a black magic manner by tapping into
this exception and giving place and
giving room to the exception so you it
all this can help you understand the
kind of black magic symbolism the idea
of using uh
residues of other people's bodies like
hair or uh or menstrual blood and all of
these things that are that are dead and
that are
that are cast away from the body that
all of this imagery is related to
black magic uh also the idea of having
some kind of sexual intercourse with
strangers with prostitutes with ugly
people like alice crowley did all these
kinds of horrible rituals where he would
have relationships with with with kind
of uh disgusting people all of this is
to tap into this this uh this power of
the residue and the power of the margin
um and the power of the exception all of
this all of this is a is a tool let's
say in order to gain power in yourself
but
the inverted pentagram has way more
implications than that because
you could say that inverted pentagram is
pretty much the basic pattern of a lot
of what people believe and so when
someone says that there is such a thing
as democracy whereas the the will of the
of all the the multiplicity somehow
really does coalesce into one when
people uh believe for example that you
can derive value from facts when
scientists believe that you can arrive
at value from facts then they are in an
inverted pentagram every time that uh
you know every time that people um
believe also that the world just emerges
out of chaos without any form of spirit
without any form of unity at the top and
that everything comes from below let's
say in all of these in all of its
multiplicity right the idea that out of
different chemical elements could just
happen to come together and to form
consciousness this is all an upside down
vision of reality and it is all let's
say standing inside the uh the upside
down pentagram so you can see why in my
video where i talk about
these kind of satanic tropes i'm
alluding to the to the fact that
really modernism and modern culture is a
form of
it's a form of satanic manifestation and
i say it like almost like in a technical
way i want to be careful because
everybody
all of us in the west have made the
mistake of believing this and
participating this to a certain extent
um
and uh and so it's every time that you
don't want to submit to something above
you right that's the inverted pentagram
right
it's it's just another manifestation of
of that okay um and so you need to and
so once again we need to be careful i
mean obviously this the inverted
pentagram i would never use that image
because it's so now tied to the satanic
that you know and it makes sense it's
coherent the symbolism of it is
completely coherent it's not arbitrary
at all but there could there are
versions of that that appear strangely
and that are not necessarily tied to
evil itself so for example uh there is a
church in europe where there is in the
northern transept in the window there is
an inverted pentagram in the northern
window and so you can wonder like what
is it that they're trying to why would
they have an inverted pentagram in the
window and uh you can it doesn't take
very long to kind of understand why they
would put that there especially if you
understand the architecture of a church
as being the totality of all things
especially if you understand the reason
why there are gargoyles or there are
there are griffins on the outside of
churches a lot of orthodox think they
get out of it because they don't have
gargoyles on the outside of their
churches well a lot of greek churches
had griffins on the outside of churches
which are just
just
a a form of gargle really and so the
reason why you why they would have put
let's say an upside down pentagram at
the northern transept is because the
northern transept is the dark transept
it is the left side when you walk into a
church and you're looking east the
northern transit is left it's recognized
as the place where the sun never
is never there and usually in the
northern transept there are
strangest there they're often strange
imagery especially in kind of french uh
gothic cathedrals there are weird
imageries from the old testament for
example
a lot of images of foreigner the queen
of sheba
i went i think it was in in shaft or
maybe not or maybe it was uh in notre
dame in paris they have images of the
story of the golden hemrods you know on
the beasts where the ark goes out into
the into the foreigner into the foreign
land to the wilderness um like i said
the queen of sheba and the images of
these strangers that are in the old
testament and so it's the place
of the unknown the place of darkness the
place of you know this residue like in
the story of the of the um the golden
hemorrhoids for example and ultimately
all of this plays a part in the story
like all of this is part of reality
sometimes uh
sometimes even even uh despite the
people who are embodying this symbolism
one of the things i hinted at in my
article on the american conservative is
how
these satanists you know they they think
they're being really clever and they
think they're being really smart but
ultimately they're actually
without even knowing what they're doing
they're going to participate in the
return of christianity just like by
killing christ the satan didn't
understand that he was participating in
the salvation of the world this
symbolism this kind of dark upside down
symbolism will ultimately and inevitably
call back to the other side will
inevitably be like this strange dark
mirror that at some point uh uh will
inevitably call back the normal order of
things and uh a return of the logos and
so maybe that can give you a little bit
of hope in these dark times and so make
sure you understand what i said i'm not
saying that you should be sporting
upside down pentagrams and you should be
sporting all that like i said it is
especially the way it's used today a
very dark and coherent imagery um but
rather just understand that christ is
stronger than all of this that god is is
above and beyond these considerations
and that
uh you know
the story is going to play out how it's
going to play out and truth will always
win in the end and so i hope this was
useful in kind of understanding a little
bit the symbolism of the upside down
pentagram and thank you everybody for
your support and i will talk to you very
soon